myanmar's military government has
executed four political prisoners
including a prominent lawmaker and a
well-known democracy activist the four
men had challenged last year's military
coup now among those hanged were
a member of the elected ruling party and
the veteran activist chomin yu better
known as ko jimmy the military accused
all four men of being involved in
terrorist killings and the executions
have been widely condemned by
international observers many more
political prisoners are facing similar
charges
and for more we can cross straight to
i'm in town a journalist from myanmar
who now lives in exile welcome to dw
what more can you tell us about these
four men and the
circumstances of their executions
so far very little is known about the
actual executions um even the manner of
execution is currently unclear the
military has not confirmed how it is
they were killed but most are presuming
that it was a hanging because that is
how executions have been carried out in
the past
we do know that the families were
allowed to speak with
the four men before they were executed
on friday however they weren't told at
the time that the men were going to be
executed the military also played koi
over the weekend about whether or not
they were about to carry out the
sentences although because the families
were allowed to meet with them for the
first time since their sentencing many
had speculated that this would be
carried out today
what signal is the military junta
sending would you say by carrying out
these executions
the military has been facing quite a lot
of resistance from people within the
country including many of its own
officials as well as
soldiers police and and those who work
for the military being the target of
assassination campaigns as well as
active conflict in many areas of the
country
given that there are over a hundred
people who are now on death row uh
who have been sentenced since the
military came out uh many believe that
this is a tactic to try to install uh
instill more fear into the population uh
but it's quite unlikely that this is
going to be successful although that
although there's quite a lot of anger in
the country
um over uh 2100 people have already been
killed by the military and so many are
unlikely to be held by these recent
actions well based on what you just said
uh what is the likely effect of these
executions on the
democracy movement in myanmar
we're likely to see quite a lot of
retaliation
after the sentencing of these men to
death to the death penalty as well as
the sentencing of other prominent
activists as well as politicians there
has been retaliatory attacks on prisons
on military officials and i think we're
likely to see another wave of attacks as
retaliation for
uh these actions and i think we're
likely to see the continual erosion of
rule of law
by people who
you know may have been um
in the past more willing to accept
military rule but are now um more and
more convinced every day that uh there
will be no justice and there will be no
rule of law under this regime
you've been vehement in your criticism
of the coup of the junta you now live in
exile
um do you hope to return to myanmar one
day
i do hope to return to myanmar one day
and i do think that um given the
strength of the resistance to the
military so far um you know this is a an
institution with over a billion dollar
budget um fighting against what a
population of largely farmers
that has been largely enabled to
solidify its role even over a year after
uh their coup um i do have hope that i
will be able to return in the future
however i think that is uh
not going to be something that's going
to happen in the next uh in the short
term at least
i'm in turn to journalist from myanmar
thank you so much for your time
thank you for having me
you